todo funciona bajo un mismo poder que es
la energía y todos nos regimos mediante
las mismas leyes las leyes naturales del
universo aquellas que ante la
información que siempre estuvo frente a
mí me cambió la vida por completo pero
no solo porque cambió mi forma de pensar
sino también de sutil y button me hizo
darme cuenta que la única persona que
mantenía en ese hoyo pero yo misma
entonces
pensamiento más sentimiento más acción y
pensamiento que tú tienes pueden ser las
ondas cerebrales o pulsos eléctricos que
viajan a través de tus neuronas
estos le permiten actual permanecer bajo
un cierto estado o realizar distintas
actividades como por ejemplo la
liberación de la familia
básicamente tu cuerpo está en constante
comunicación gracias a la energía
emitiendo energía y entonces nos guiamos
bajo supuesto la ley de acción y
reacción
esperemos esperando energía de la misma
frecuencia ingrese a nosotros todo lo
que sucede en tu vida no es más que el
reflejo de la energía que emite
por qué
es
para que podamos entender mejor
tenemos distintos niveles energéticos en
los que giran los electrones y que tiene
que suceder
distinta a la que ya posee
[Música]
nuestra vida
es una situación
[Música]
tus piernas
tu momento
[Música]
un pensamiento
por eso es que dicen que tú eres tu peor
enemigo no porque como estas tus
debilidades sino porque eres tú quien
las crea la mente tiene el poder de la
creación pero también de la destrucción
por esto también que trabajar en la
percepción que tienes de ti mismo se
vuelve realmente indispensable un
estudio muy interesante realizado por un
doctor japonés que experimentó con las
partículas del agua y su reacción a las
intenciones con las que se trabajaba
aquí está en darse estas moléculas
formaban distintas figuras mientras que
aquellas moléculas que eran sometidas a
intenciones positivas terminadas con
figuras armoniosas simétricas bonitas
aquellas que eran sometidas a atenciones
negativas música pesada insultos
maldiciones
terminaba formando figuras muy poco
simétricas
el 70 por ciento
[Música]
imagínate que estás haciendo
y por si todo esto no fuera suficiente
además los pensamientos son los grados
en positivo y pienso positivo y cosas
buenas pero qué sucede cuando lo
intentamos y nos damos de topes contra
la pared porque nos damos cuenta de que
no nos funciona
voy a contar un pequeño secreto de lo
que éramos
[Música]
sí no
es la energía se cantando por tus
pensamientos sí pero también por tus
sentimientos ahora yo sé que controlar
un sentimiento es uno de los retos más
complicados que la vida nos pone sin
embargo existen dos claves
la primera es entender que nuestros
pensamientos son producto de la
percepción que tenemos la vida de lo que
pasa en el mundo a nuestro alrededor
por su parte los sentimientos son la
liberación de nuestros presos son muy
pesados las percepciones
entonces qué va a pasar si yo me siento
en este voy a emocionar y empiezo a
hacer lo mismo
ya no tenga esperanza solamente
controlan las soluciones y si yo a esto
el cerebelo lo va a registrar y entonces
me va a dar más de un mismo porque se lo
estoy pidiendo encerrándome en este
círculo de funciones
la segunda es entender también que no se
para de eliminar las ilusiones negativas
porque al final del día son parte de tu
experiencia y ayudan a crecer hacer
mejor hasta ser más fuerte se trata de
aprender a vivirlas sentirlas pero
también aprender a soltarlas porque otra
manera pasar hasta está activa una y
otra y otra vez y temporal de minor
emocional entre 10 y 20 minutos después
de esto simplemente tu cabeza dándole
adultos en huevitos resulta evitando que
llegar a una solución
yo sé
[Música]
entonces
no importa que te levantes día
[Música]
tengo que aprender a hacer la vida para
convertirla en algo
suprema de pequeñas acciones tienen
decisiones que pasito a pasito más lejos
y tuvieron más arriba a veces para
arriba que nunca estar abajo
y todo esto me lleva al ingrediente
número 3 último pero no menos importante
porque yo no te estoy alentando a tu
casa a pensar
se trata de algo la opción es ofrecer
ingrediente
y esto estaría siendo la mejor versión
de mi vida y entonces convertirse en
ello alineando tu pensamiento con tus
sentimientos con tus acciones
cuenta de que cuando todo permanezca
igual pero tu llamado veas de la misma
manera
[Música]
ser honesto
lo que ocurre en el tazón
y resulta que todo esto no nos enseña
mente secundaria pero en ese momento de
tu vida no tienes la capacidad para
asociarlo directamente con lo que te
sucede la realidad escribes toda una
vida con todas las herramientas
necesarias con el conocimiento necesario
para ponerse una venda sobre los ojos
porque la mente tiene un mecanismo de
defensa que nos aleja
vamos a conocer este mecanismo de
defensa llamado miedo para detener
y entonces es cuando a ti te toca
aprender a controlar tu mente y no que
tu mente el control
quiero contarles de hecho que estoy aquí
y hoy es el final de nada
nada cambia sin nada también tú tienes
la oportunidad de salir por esa puerta
con una pequeña espinita que puede
investigar a leer informarte a
profundizar entonces estos temas que
siempre han estado frente a ti y es
recibido más de quitarte la venda de los
ojos y entonces saber si quieres
intentar la curiosidad si felipe no
estar aquí yo estoy poniendo todas las
herramientas en tus manos todo el
conocimiento necesario recuperar lo que
quieras
una cosa
y nada que perder
que puedo ganar así simplemente todo lo
que deseas
vamos
[Aplausos]